louder with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter and hopper
[Applause]
[Music]
louder with Crowder's spooktacular u of
m takeover October 25th
overflow room now at Pierpoint Commons
lounge with costume contest giveaways
and a whole lot of scares don't miss it
I just want to you know laugh about
things every night Bill Cosby says that
being declared a sexually violent
predator is going to damage his
reputation not available for comment
were all the women that he raped
[Music]
it doesn't stop here - one way it
doesn't stop
[Music]
[Music]
that's the sound of the week until you
are you are you are you petting your
Walter I am very grateful up their
sponsors to your show with a great show
today we have Jim DeFede on the show
latest video will be talking about we
have Dean Cain in the show and of course
we have in third chair one Benjamin huge
pns comm huge pianist calm how you doing
it's great to be back my friend
and then before a hold on before I bring
everyone else in question of the day
slow news week I was a couple of stories
though so what bothers you more the
media outrage at Donald Trump's warning
to the Mexican care man or Hollywood's
retroactive feminist outrage at Disney
Princesses comment below we're gonna be
discussing those producing of course
quarterblack cares that's awful I'm
ashamed of this program and we got a
little bit Rudy Asst Rudy Asst Rudy is
having a Sauvignon that the one who
sacks the quarterback you know he was
undeserving to be in that team that's
Rudy do not like that move the team oh
you made the team by being a janitor you
know a Rudy it's not true haven't seen
in a while yo I hear my dad talk about
Rudy you like he didn't deserve the spot
he did it's true
he didn't deserve what was it he
shouldn't have been there in the first
place any speaking shouldn't be you will
be at the show at U of M yes I will as
will notice Angie October 25th yeah a
lot going on I tried to stop at
Eventbrite Orlov credit comes much to
her and it was sold out no no we
actually just reserved a big-ass room
Pierre points common lounge it'll be an
overflow party with prizes the costume
contest and our buddy Eric Nimr will be
will be there
nice live yeah so we'll be going back to
up here points calming lounge by sky
because we couldn't really get Hill
Auditorium there's a lot of stuff going
on does just don't cross it off your
list don't cross it off come hang out
you're gonna be a blast in the lounge
ourselves by the way leading the news
see we finally got the news Donald Trump
of course this is the Twitter is all
abuzz about this we should warning to
Mexico about the migrant caravan heading
to a border this came to us from CNBC I
must in the strongest of terms Donald
Trump's at esque Mexico to stop this odd
slot and if I'm unable to do so I will
call up the US military and then in all
caps close our southern border yeah
Gordon they're obviously getting all
this I was getting a little dicey here
and some people are concerned that we
actually obtained exclusive audio yeah
from president Trump's call to the
brethren in Mexico well kind of hello
Mexico yeah sure you just like taco I
know it's you at their pad yeah okay now
I know frankly how to print out the
little Ed's with the squiggly hat and I
know because you guys tricked me last
year at New Year's when I said I know
you filthy son of a okay quit the games
you tricky little [ __ ] listen about
that care of Ed Pena stop giving them
gasoline gasoline oh no point oh okay
and I'll take it out yograj I got I got
the dad I got a dad joke what caravan
more likes caravan wow we led with that
people but how terrible are like all of
the other countries are basically
pointing them north and handing them a
map like they're not stopping them at
any borders or anything I think you're
trying to escape hell but don't come
here go to Canada by the way around it
is not hell because there are no claims
that are inferior and or so that's nice
Central America has just never gotten it
together their veins are you have to
chimera that down there like giving them
water and Gatorade guys keep going I
don't know I guess well let's just pivot
there's there's no there's nowhere else
to mine here so turning to I guess
Entertainment News Amy Schumer said that
she feels quote really bad for women
more attractive than her a lot of women
I think a specific woman in the
interview is what spurred it she said
quote being a woman sucks I feel really
bad for these girls who are so hot
because guys can't handle it you can't
have a conversation I actually feel
really bad for them oh that's so sweet
respond the woman in question while her
boyfriend used Amy Schumer to help her
over a puddle what a gentleman that is a
gentleman yeah attractive woman where
her foot
placement is like just to add insult to
injury right right to the future to
think about like leftist they they don't
see individuals so it's just women when
she says I feel bad for women or it
sucks being a woman she's basically
saying it sucks being me and I don't
know how to say individuals so I just
say a demographic yeah yeah this is like
a beatdown plate and every stocks being
fat and [ __ ] socks
I feel bad for you because you're in
better shape than me like the fact that
you just have you just have the big the
big hips because you're you were a
football player listen I can Bob I give
God some don't pout you're stronger I'm
wearing black so it doesn't show you're
stronger leaner and quicker let's be
honest freak athlete here is Gerald at
Jim Morgan Jr is all that wine I guess
it's beating up on Michigan's actually
actually I guess helps a prevent s good
cardio best estrogen buildup in the body
aroma taste I guess I guess the
resveratrol and wine is good for that
yeah definitely hope that's why you have
that's why you don't have ladies to give
you nightmares well anyway you were
taught you just talking about like a
complete sociopath you don't even talk
you're not looking at jails or me
looking like this
well then I see my thoughts ahead ones
like a cat he's always plotting our doom
no protective I'm like plotting but it's
good stuff yeah James O'Keefe Dean Cain
coming up something that gives children
nightmares there's a video from a police
dashcam which shows we have video right
you actually shows despite a giant
spider ready and poised to attack a
traffic cop oh my gosh yeah do we have a
clip
that is look the thing is just it's
ready to pounce that is absolutely
terrible terrified the spider by the way
was later detained and questioned
regarding assault on a police officer as
well as his involvement with the
arachnid Brotherhood so that does seem
yeah okay okay that's like spider-man's
older brothers that gotten a mess you
know he wasn't all about helping people
he's all about our mess yeah deep fear
of spiders by the way this is this is
like snake island what you did to me oh
you say snake island actually in an area
of several areas of Texas but South
Dallas there are these spiders that now
actually work as a team and you will see
it have whole canvases Oh lighter webs
over them oh yeah yeah we were driving
by there one from we're on a road trip
johnny-boy and I what what is that we
walked up and it's just the look on her
face which oh it's just oh it almost
looks as though your it looks as though
you're staring at a tree through a
cheesecloth and a film of spiders we
made a spider or tweet the pictures I
instantly know now that you say that I
didn't know it was a team about camel
spiders oh yeah they're not really
spiders though technically what are they
what are they
there are technically closer to the
scorpion family yeah they eat like
lizards and stuff they're gigantic
so my buddies that served in the Middle
East says they'll go in a camel and just
I don't know I mean I'm very good mr.
visual with you do it we'll show him
again
we got it it's that's important up for
me that really ought that drove the
point home otherwise I would have been
very confused thing to the audio sorry
so finally if spiders don't terrify you
there's there's this tryna think about
introduced it just there's no way to
it's a new viral video entitled my
partner identifies as a dog yeah
I've been involved in a pet play for my
entire life a lot of people like to play
pretend that's a man tend to be an
animal yeah there's no man to woman
doing it I just never been a man and a
woman yeah start dating let's not put
this in our time capsules they say when
the student is ready the monster appears
yeah all the S&M gear yeah oh
every boy dreams of man's best friends
is it okay to call her [ __ ] Timmy's in
the well you want to do weird sex tricks
to him okay boy good girl girl good
actor was a boy yeah it's no longer good
enough just to be gay yeah you really
have to outdo the nice love just what is
this this is normally they're dressed up
as a dog with leather chokers and the
ball gag with the whole like ever gets
to go through a PowerPoint to tell their
parents they want a dog I'm gonna walk
it I'm gonna feed it I will brush it
that's not what Sarah McLachlan added
fine hard to bleep on that
what is completely both ways yeah the
trans if you look at the common we're
gonna hey whatever you want to do to
live your truth and in the same thing by
the way it is it's a transgender I think
male to female a female to male so who'd
have thought that surprised you'd keep
on going down that slippery slope and to
living as a dog and he says you know
puppy plays you as well or he goes I
don't know just hey hang me from the
gallows for saying the wrong thing I
don't know whatever yeah just just and
he says she says like well no actually
I'm a real dog but then later let's just
play it say oh you're a real dog yeah
but that's a crime no no I'm not a real
dog because you still have sex with me
you know but we can just treat these
people as crazy if they were if they
were okay with like yeah I'm kind of
psychotic
that'd be okay with that but they're
saying no I'm completely normal well
devised mental illness yes I just hope
Michael Vick kills this person we can
put them in the ring dogfighting when
it's actually good my I think it doesn't
kill anybody I always had a choice
it was tryouts who let the dogs out who
dog you're just lying dog related titled
it's just getting a little lazy that's
Augie dog he's a snoop now it's like
boys at Puff Daddy P Diddy than just
Diddy yeah they keep changing I think
John Combs Mark Sean Combs
so let me trigger the strawberry so
she's a male to female transgender
before becoming a duck so it's just this
complete concoction of perversion you're
crazy so which is bruised screwed up at
what's crazy it means what right now
we're actually you know you know this is
absurd yeah yeah we're just talking yeah
sure about jazz Jennings yesterday know
yesterday was advocate two days ago
talking about his her her penis or his
penis to a girl I know it's a slice it
in half inverted banana split that whole
business and you have to make sure
there's enough tissue so that you can do
that inject yourself full of cancerous
estrogen we know what it does to the
male body when injected in an excess
amounts and this person then still by
the way doesn't change your chromosomes
doesn't affect the body tries to close
it as a womb yeah and then they say well
we all go along no you don't get the
drug every seer is the point everyone
has a line you don't get to draw the
line on someone putting on S&M gear
walking around like a tamagotchi or nano
pet when you allow jazz Jennings they
are both equally absurd you don't get to
draw your own line by the way there's
more to this I actually spoke with my
fiance who's in the medical field about
this and apparently you have to keep
inserting something into it yes
and gradually be bigger because it's
close and close itself at the wound does
it change him because no you're still
thinking about the dog this is the
filleting of the penis we'll go back to
something more sane like how is it not
an illness if you require surgery and a
wife is a nurse I want to yes yes you
basically said so you have to insert a
a dildo or some sort whatever right and
you have to whoa whoa sorry you can
believe that I guess I don't know and
then you have to keep it like it doesn't
produce its own moisture and so you have
to keep it like that
wait is that actually a thing no about
that we're not supposed to you can't use
the word moisture on the show yeah we're
gonna block them yeah that's a bleep for
sure it's just just like with
transgenderism where caitlyn jenner just
becomes a walking Barbie doll right it's
like hey I think I'm all of the
stereotypes that we you know have
perfected that we have perpetuated a
society or a patriarchal society of
women down that's all these transgenders
really attempt to fulfill they just end
up being a walking stereotypical woman
but we never call on that as totally
accept that it's the same thing here
these people they're only attempting to
perpetuate the fun stereotype of a dog
at least wouldn't win oh and I reload
the weekends we put some commitment into
it did you take a dump on my laptop woof
why would they dress as a blueberry for
some reason I don't know I think you're
chewing bubblegum I was in Willy Wonka
or opposed to I already feel awkward
seeing dogs poop out in the wild like
they always look over their shoulder at
you like why you looking at me if I saw
a human being doing this dress up as a
dog I don't know what I would do hopper
doesn't look you in the eye hey that's
no fear like a Hodgman yeah I don't like
the word either maybe like grossed me
out
I know really you wouldn't fare well in
Germany or San Francisco okay so
everyone everyone got all this topic are
we good yeah we're good
you can I got one more joke about it
okay this person has to go door-to-door
Petco to say that they're a sex offender
who let the dogs out that's it that's
all I got look at Penn [ __ ] ya little
bow-wow no Romeo yeah well now you're
not even dog just saying things with Lil
I don't know okay so we're gonna be
talking about because it's a slow news
week but I think this macro context
matters coming off the transgender dog
story Keira Knightley and here is it
Kristen or Kirsten I always get that
wrong I don't really care you know made
news recently for taking issue with the
classic Disney Princess film so both
kind of towards different approaches but
again if you
Google keira knightley if you google
Kristen Bell you can see just just the
laundry list of feminist complaints and
male bashing but in this instance they
were both very specific about the Disney
films they hate and why let's let's
start with nightly problems with I think
Little Mermaid in Cinderella Cinderella
mm-hmm and because you know she ate she
waits around for a rich guy to rescue
her don't rescue I mean the suns are
great but do not give your voice up for
a man made so I'm having that one's a
little tricky one bit now but I'm
kidding to give your voice up for a map
didn't Ariel gain King legs pretty good
trades a trade-off yeah it's a great
trade if walk on land by the way good
bravery going on a lesbians talk show
bashing men I dunno I will say that I
I'm gonna be won over all right this was
followed by Kristen Bell I think this is
an over like there's no clip of this
finding Snow White problematic saying
that she wasn't comfortable with Disney
films these are some quotes from Kristen
Bell every time we closed Snow White and
a look at my girls I asked don't you
think it's weird that snow white didn't
ask the old witch why she needed to eat
the apple or where she got that Apple I
say I would never take food from a
stranger would you and okay
nope this is by the way lit in the
article comes from parents come when she
talks about why she's uncomfortable to
Disney film that's the point the point
to it the witch work that is the
stranger danger it's a conversation
starter it's like Aesop family just they
can't write what are you setting to
follow the bouncing Aesop along the
bottom of the screen to learn to let
it's your job as a parent which goes eat
the apple and she starts convulsing in a
seizure for you go see bad things happen
are you just stupid to have children how
is this a problem that's the point
well the hilarious part is that she was
a princess in frozen she was Anna yeah I
know that let's try said the old ones
are bad the new ones right like she's
like Jack and Jill went up the hill to I
got nothing I hate these people
it's like the whole point Kevin Spacey
says tell me more about Jack did you
break his crown
what's a crown did he get to fix did you
break my crown is polishing straw you
know you saw the ride you butter took it
anyway
Bev Christa's go she goes time to add
don't you think that it's weird that the
prince kisses Snow White without her
permission because you cannot kiss
someone when they're sleeping
congratulations
firstly you've completely missed the
point of a fairy tale this is unreal
this is just the macro issue that now
all of a sudden there's a problem this
idea of princesses and princes and a
dragon distantly were talking on this
with Jocko there's a great book called
wild at heart it's human nature but now
it's become the movement just like me
too everyone's afraid to speak out so
Disney's been inundated with feminist
complaints lately and unfortunately been
crafting more modern fairy tales in
response princess we were here to save
ya know she can save herself she looks
at you look plenty and power that
breachers got a handle you know it's not
because we're man decides the English
page took a hard turn that's a burn
victim out there Ariel do you need now
we can't hear you
helper if she does oh [ __ ] she's
actively asked for it
title 9 you stay away from no joke
because she's and all the pop castles
that's the devil's triangle
you mean like the drinking game no seen
that coming Hollywood now thinks a fairy
tale is just a snappy story from a gay
guy yeah I just thought that Wow
no little boys like rescuing princesses
and little girls like being pretend
rescued yes here's something else that
people don't notice it and we'll get
into each kind of it we'll go through a
few examples of Disney I think it's
important to get into the specifics down
now why does this matter than why you
spend so much time in Disney for the
same reason that people complain about
there not being enough black people in
in films and then I laughed my ass off
and eating the Beast when they come on
there's a give and take there aren't
enough female foot sabers I get madness
that there aren't enough female
directors you see that the the whatever
one of the producers at bloom house if
they're frankly just aren't that many
factors out and they go this is an
alternate and they said well we have a
hefty list of women who would be
qualified and they have the one woman
who did monster and Wonder Woman I'm
friends with her she's cool too and then
the others are like Penniston when
directed a bunch of x-files episodes my
problem here is just that we're saying
all people have to be all things and we
have to change anything retroactively it
might be considered offensive and I
don't think there's anything offensive
about this yeah if you look at the way
these women these female princesses and
Disney are portrayed their always
portrayed as capable but submissive like
Snow White
Ariel Cinderella and then the men are
always portrayed as strong men who are
gentle and loving with the one man who
will slay the tensed but gentle it's a
firm with the bad guys like this that's
actually how we're called to be as
husbands and wives biblically and it's
also what's best for society it's couple
there's something wrong and that's the
part of the Bible that most people skip
over because it says wives be submissive
to your husbands but right after that it
says husbands like your women lay down
your life for her right nothing wrong
with laying down your life for your wife
ok yeah it's ok she should be submissive
in that point then it goes on to say a
wife laid down for your husband oh yeah
all day
some are gonna be black boys that
revelation I saw before me no like
religious stop it saying all day our day
[Laughter]
Cinderella because that's what cinema
was a love story I actually what I see
Cinderella I don't know what you think I
see it as a good example of a man
helping a woman out of an abusive
relationship
of course exactly what is real no more
likely to be abusive by the way
emotionally abusive that's more common
than men oh my god that's a good thing
they're the real villains that's there
was metaphorical dragons by the way
Prince Charming both in Cinderella and
is this kind of archetype again gentle
caring no tolerance for evil cruelty
yeah he seeks out the goodness in
Cinderella and this is against
Cinderella look at Cinderella she's very
capable she's smart she's pretty but
she's submissive she's not offing the
stepsisters which most of us would do
that's that's the appropriate response
his job to come in and do that because
it shows complementarianism right like a
PFF sort of locket yeah we complement
each other whether you got gaps I got
gaps together we fill gaps so true she
uses her one wish to be proactive in fix
the situation and then the prince is
looking saying oh listen I'm gonna use
this slipper just to guarantee that I
don't wind up with those [ __ ] right
it's a it's good all around things would
you get notification bail because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot on
YouTube and join my club if you're
enjoying the show and hopefully you're
enjoying the show ah a lot of credit
that come slash smoke let me get this
show every single day it helps support
the show and also subscribe on iTunes
please rate us because I kind of want to
know where feminists want us to fall
down right now because we're this toxic
masculinity thing that's being portrayed
out there in the culture is that men are
too overbearing and then you get this
prince in these shows right that is
actually not overbearing at all he's
chivalrous he serves he helps people he
defeats the dragon like you said he does
aerobic where do you want us you're
telling us that was really bad in one
way and in the opposite direction
there's no safe quarter there either 1%
of course
[Laughter]
could heaven pawning the one gold it's a
hair about Savannah Savannah's in
Georgia well there isn't a fan in Africa
I'm straining with them Gilbert go well
it's uh this wife no it's nonsense is
the thing to say promote or insane like
Fifty Shades of Grey
yes like they have no problem with that
that's like 50 counts of rape doesn't
cost as much as a freaking crystal
slipper yeah they don't want good guys
they don't want the prints they want
they want a a billionaire to put you in
a red room and simulate rape I mean
that's an insane movie but the name is
Christian which is another funny thing
to me the people for stuff I'm much more
inclined to believe the devil's triangle
we didn't talk about this a ton on there
is a drinking game because you're
writing about it publicly in your
yearbook and again we're using urban
dictionary from the last five years to
try and apply it bad les les Calvin I
had a DeLorean triangle doesn't mean
rape since when does Hollywood care
about sexual perversion every single
movie obsessed with sodomy that's yeah
that's crazy out words will switch like
square used to be a compliment back in
the day and then it became an insult
yeah they bet like 60 years ago if you
said someone was square it meant they
were a good guy they were squared up
yeah and that became like a nerd
it's like words just keep changing and
changing yeah now I think it's
absolutely right like so next one is
sure why that used to be in the
postmenopausal woman with no children or
a very drunk man because it meant a
burdensome person it's fascinating
I knew bundle of sticks under lipstick
yeah because that was like Adam or
you're like it's on your back of the
burden oh yeah and it also meant gays
cuz yeah kids yeah yeah I just use it
for gays
so the next family is snow we're gonna
clatters Snow White
let's go to Snow White okay so the
princess and Snow White hides from an
evil witch who went to kill snow white
right in order to be the most beautiful
of them all kind of sounds like Amy
Schumer story from earlier she's in a
puddle now they're bitching about
kissing someone who's sleeping in yeah
the context does matter context over
content keep in mind it Snow White has
already fallen love
with the prints here's a clip evidence
[Music]
singing he's clearly a but she's not in
on it yeah yeah she's no no look look at
this I love she's into it okay this
means I want to bear your children okay
equivalent to consent I don't care what
happens at the time what the point is
she likes I don't know you think of
woman does this because you rape her
yeah if there were any doubt as to how
she felt about the Prince she goes on
the sing about meeting her prince again
here's another clip rape sing the same
way back that's enough that's enough
that's no life thing but the point is
here I mean it's it could not be clearer
that she likes the prince something
weird the girl has a [ __ ] fetish she
with seven midgets one with a drinking
problem woman arkla I'm pretty sure one
of them was bipolar like there's a lot
weird with this film it looked at the
moment the two with they're sitting in
like huh what was a cokehead sneezy yes
they prefer to be called people
McNuggets though I think we've talked
about I think of a little trooper you
need to clear that up little trooper why
it's what the Snow White was 1/1000 24th
Native American though she wasn't that
means it's okay to rape her I guess is
what you're saying I have no idea where
this went scallop I guess it's okay to
scallop a consent there's Caliphate okay
here's something else that people don't
remember snow white that when the prince
kisses snow white by the way he's been
seeking he's been he oh he's gone
through the witch write this it's not
always a dragon at the point is he
fought somebody off to rescue the
princess there is sacrifice this is
another constant that we see not only
through all literary work of fiction
pretty much but particularly in business
films Disney films there's sacrifice at
the altar of self effectively you are
sacrificing something that would
obviously be good for it for someone
else that's part of a relationship
that's actually a good lesson so the
princes sacrifice his safety in a lot of
ways
obviously he's basically leaving the
safety of the kingdom searching for Snow
White when he finds her by the way he
doesn't think she's sleeping you think
she's dead looks dead to me on a second
you have to blur this here comes the
rape we did have to edit out that hasn't
that one grumpy just gonna how the
difference kissing used to be safe right
you could you could be dancing with a
girl at a party or something like that
and you feeling the vibe she doesn't
like pull away you kiss her and you
weren't accused of rape you remember
that now we have dating apps that have
consent that you can actually click on
both of you know that you have consent
in writing before you do something like
that she knows that real that's
absolutely really consent when you sign
up for the dating app I thought consent
was what did you think you were signing
up for MySpace no no it's an app just
for consent it's not a dating I know oh
it's like a form yes like an video you
can you can select yes I get my iPad to
this yeah how romantic is that by the
way I'd like the planning second base
third yeah nothing weird right I think
we're all starting to just realize that
sexual being a sexual conservative is
the way to go like people can't handle
this is not good for women right there
almost like reverting back to old school
morality because this tinder thing is
making them feel like a soft rape all
the time right if they're not made for
it it's a fact I believed a lie when I
was in my 20s it's not true and my wife
by the way if I kissed her sweetly while
she was sleeping
she'd be fired up she'd be like oh
that's really nice but usually I just go
get coffee and do my own thing
usually I just have sex with mine oh
it's not he's winning you're there your
wife yeah
wife doesn't matter you can do it
wakefulness does not equal consent um
it's like this does she sleep like this
that's why that means married offensive
it's an a very defensive oh God
I cut are your wife yeah alright but so
basically you treat your wife like a
little brother where you're doing the
loogie we have to move this train along
Little Mermaid as they use it so the
Little Mermaid is basic about a young
woman choosing a different life of it
despite the expectations of her
feminists see this as a woman giving up
her voice for a man again sacrifice
isn't it was it was her choice yes and
by the way it wasn't the complete
sacrifice she treated a voice for legs
yeah and she was singing underwater hid
here under waters are so not her own dad
or did her dad get like killed or
something because of her choices I
haven't known you're giving to dislike
yeah why did she didn't she need did she
have to give up her job what she had
quadruplets she changed a job through
the joy and wonder of motherhood right
there are trade-offs especially in
relationships their trust by the way
from the knot the print is it a prince
and in little read the guy the guy with
the puffy shirt you know I think he's a
prince you know he's going after her I'm
gonna pretty sure he lost his
inheritance the guy's kept busy with a
fish there's a puppy shirt he's a prince
and also it's kind of ableism to think
that you can't have a voice and you're
not cool I wish I didn't have a voice at
the points I talk too much I wish that
someone to take my voice if someone was
if someone could take your voice or your
legs
what would you keep I would keep legs
yeah really I keep legs I would become
really creative I always like the dudes
in movies like that don't talk a lot and
I talked so much like John wick it's
great just doesn't talk he just loves
his dog and killing Russian people it's
not only concentrate I want to hear what
you think about this I mean we have five
women who had pulled your ladder with
crowder yeah and all of them agreed
except maybe one or two different points
it's like now when I was young I played
I played a princess yeah I wanted to be
rescued yeah and here's one thing to
hold your nose here because here comes a
cold water the idea that young girls
should be taught to simply rescue
themselves by the
as Kristen Bell it's not always great
either you know why because I can't just
like men if left to their own devices
women would not be able to physically
protect themselves just like men would
not do well taking care of themselves
without the support its
complementarianism Disney inadvertently
recognized the virtue and traditional
heterosexual relationships and the
values that each person brings uniquely
there and guess guess what if Bowser
wants to kidnap peach he's kidnapping
peach he's a freakin drag in the breeze
fire she's 120 pound princess with a
Sunbrella there's no chance in hell
she's getting our life are you tossing a
couple of hairy back human fire hydrant
sized plumbing Italians the numbers game
increases a little bit I love that game
by the way Mario Mario yes that was epic
a guy goes and rescues the princess
every single time and here's this it but
if she chose in another castle that's
true the area every time how dare she
and one other thing that really bothers
me is not only can you not look at
previous words that we talked about
Devil's Triangle with today's definition
but I don't think that fiction is up to
interpretation that's part of what is
enjoyable about fictions that you can
kind of take from it what you want I
understand that that being said not all
interpretations are as valid so the
families of looking at the same well
hold on a second I'm watching Disney I'm
seeing I'm seeing Beauty and the Beast
and I'm seeing a woman who's locked in
it's not missing a strong intelligent
nerdy woman he's also getting stuffed
and sacrifices her well-being for her
father right to save his life and then
ultimately she sacrifices herself for
the Beast for the Beast left then the
Beast ends up sacrificing himself
against Gaston for the woman this is all
about self-sacrifice this is all about
people actually being brave and dying to
oneself as we know it's Christians you
die to the flesh every single day that's
what this is about I know that they
didn't necessarily mean it to be that
deep but it's not fair to look at these
old Disney films through today's lens
and act as though your interpretation is
just as valid no because they don't want
food ask the screenwriter if you would
ask the author whoever Sevan was this
meant to be an auntie woman scream was
just really meant to and the guy would
say no that's what Stephen said it was
yeah I was just a princess damsel you
know he said it's correct it's just
their own confirmation that was the
intent of the author and to try and act
as though it was and the reason we're
doing is
we want to act there's some kind of
conspiratorial patriarchy behind Disney
films now credit the phallic symbol on
top of the castle and the old Little
Mermaid VHS that's a little messed up
there's wieners in it penis that's a
peen multiple erections and erection yes
I forgot about that one that's pretty
creepy really creepy it was Kevin Spacey
yeah why are they not complaining about
that that's the problem is that wieners
little boys need a princess to rescue
and little girls want a boy to rescue
them it doesn't mean that they're
helpless by the way here's some let me
ask you this let me put it this way you
get home okay and let's say your wife
for most men okay let's just go with men
sir I'm not gonna try not to so it's the
same on both sides so for a man you come
home your wife makes dinner did you need
her to do that no do you like it yeah
did you want it yes woman you come home
woman woman you come home your man's got
you flowers did you need him to get you
flowers does that mean that you're
helpless does that mean that you're weak
no it means he did something nice for
you and he's probably more effective at
getting you a surprise gift of flowers
than you can for yourself unless you're
a paranoid schizophrenic like Bernie
Sanders he's the only one it wasn't
fries it was flowers that's a nice thing
just like somebody fighting off the
dragon it's a nice thing just like a
woman sacrificing something for her man
because she loves him greater than the
item that she is sacrificing it's a good
thing instead we say all these things
are bad let's go put ball gags on our
dogs let's come back after this with
James O'Keefe and Dean Cain I can't do
this
we interrupt this program with breaking
news of our with Fowler I'm teri Martha
from Canada who now legalized marijuana
across the country thrusting the nation
in the international spotlight as a
national experiment though the future
remains uncertain
economists are forecasting Canada to
remain an unproductive and mostly
inconsequential country
we'll keep you abreast of the story
unfold for breaking news the louder with
brother I'm Barry Maha
[Music]
[Music]
it is fly our next guest is fly and he's
very much he's got to fly gosh
Owen really ruins me with the puns I'm
Tara twisting hands and the play on
words
you know I'm project very to us is where
of course you can support him project
very test comm you fell them on the
Twitter at James O'Keefe the third the
third now James and people of us know
who you are is that spelled with three
eyes capitalized my debts
he was okey my grandfather's James
O'Keefe so I'm Roman numeral three James
O'Keefe III Roman numeral three ok good
litter what if someone enters in James
O'Keefe and the actual number three on
Twitter do you come up or be a different
that'll be someone who is full of to be
me I'm not verified on Twitter Steve and
I've got four hundred and sixty thousand
followers but Jack Dorsey has not
verified the on Twitter yet well say let
me check this out if I type in James
O'Keefe just yeah it's just a Twitter
egg with a pic it seems as though you
should appear before that all right ah
there's a segue why why is it well you
know what first off let's let's go to a
clip of your latest video it's making
the rounds there's been a lot of a lot a
lot of fallout from it for those who
aren't aware here's a short clip
I asked while she was here and she told
me she supports an IRB and bump stock
van and I capacity magazine man I'm here
saying there is not people can go of
course predict greatest calm go to
YouTube I'm sure there are plenty of
place where they can find it as long as
you are not in D platformed oh what's
the what's the widest Claire McCaskill
hate you so much it seems that the
reaction has been really severe well
because well the reaction we caught
we've done this two stories one in
Tennessee one in Missouri and these red
states these Democrats have to appeal to
moderate voters so we talked to their
staff in some cases we talked to the
candidate and they say well we really
have to mislead voters which essentially
lie is what the McCaskill campaign
staffer says to get elected we have
we're just like Obama but quote people
can't know that so we as we do covertly
recorded this we stand now McCaskill
wants to appoint a special prosecutor to
criminalize what I have done yeah
instead of the expose it's now a crime
for me to do this and now she said that
the her opponent was involved that's
outrageous I responded so all this fall
out Stephen in every local TV station is
covering it and there's a debate there's
a there's a Senate debate tonight in
Missouri so this whole thing is sort of
blown up do you think she still is a
little bit upset that she obviously
represents a a previous slave state do
you think there's some do you think
she's just it's just some guilt bubbling
over I think there's a lot of bit
bizarre dynamics I'm not from I'm from
New Jersey I'm new to Missouri thing but
I think that the politics of Missouri
are so bizarre because people a
Democratic Party a very moderate mm-hmm
and they have to kind of deceive certain
voters and they're all admitting this
it's sort of the political reality well
it's the political reality of the
Midwest do you think it's because it's
sort of that Midwest appeal where you
have kind of the the worker sort of this
Union mentality this sort of Beltway
kind of traditionally blue blue dog
democrats but they're not really the
dyed-in-the-wool left us like you would
have in San Francisco or in Portland and
so the Democrat politicians kind of try
to they try to fake as though they
represent that do you think that's a
portion of it I think that's I think
that that is correct I think that there
are certain states like Missouri and
there are dying parts of the Democratic
Party and and and in order to get
elected into the Senate as a Democrat in
that state you have to mislead or at
least they think they do so that we
recorded all these staffers it's their
words not mine again I'm not like Bob
Woodward I don't relay anonymous quoted
sources from other sources six months
after the fact I only report it if you
can see it and hear it coming out of the
person's own mouth so she's upset Claire
McCaskill issued this bizarre statement
that I'm affiliated with her opponent
which is absolutely categorically false
and and then this guy Holly denied it
and now she's calling for a special
prosecutor
it's blown up and let's prosecute for
what what what crime are they trying to
say that you've committed here because
they're single-particle sense the the
ambiguous fraud I committed fraud it's
legal to record in Missouri one party
consent state there's no duty to keep
confidential in fact I would argue I
have a civic duty to make public new
revelations that they people were saying
but this is just what they do Steve and
I'm a controversial figure people don't
like being exposed that's irrefutable
nature of it it's just so damning and I
think it's just an incredibly damning
piece of video that we've got and and
the the knee-jerk reaction is to just
put him in jail put O'Keefe in jail it's
like well for what it's not it's not
criminal to record someone especially if
they're saying these things and it needs
to be it needs to be disseminated as far
as I'm concerned and you've done this
quite a bit have you ever had someone
just go that's one for you James
you got me you caught me just sort of
come clean after has that ever actually
happened I yes it has it's a sort of
fascinating question because I think
once in a while even people on the Left
they'll send me private emails the New
York Times or The Washington Post they
do send me private emails private
messages and they'll say that's how did
you one of them said how did you get
that guy to talk
like they're they're impressed by what
we're able to show because if you if
you're a traditional reporter your
sources are either anonymous or they're
on the record and and they're not gonna
be as honest and they're not going to be
as transparent so you when you have when
you have campaign officials saying we
have to lie to get elected it's so it's
so damning and I stay like Missouri the
what she's saying banning semi-automatic
rifles in New Jersey or California or
New York that might sound like I'm like
a typical you cannot say that no in
Missouri and get elected and even so
that you could not say it in New Jersey
if people in New Jersey could understand
what semi-automatic rifle meant or read
it but particularly as it relates to
some people think semi-automatically
think it's first fire it just means
pretty much every rifle that's not a
pump-action shotgun or lever-action
rifle so even then it's really just
because a lot of these people who are
bicoastal they're not entirely aware of
what these what these these terms mean
no I was talking more as far as someone
you've actually stung I guess yeah it's
stabilized it like hanged hung or is a
sting sting with a sting operation any
actual subject as any one of them just
said you know what James got me all
right I'm I'm bowing out here because I
did say it that is true have you ever
you know stielike it Ted I did confront
I did confront like you know 60 minutes
Mike Wallace used to do this I've
started do this now where I confront the
subject on the street so what
McCaskill's guy nixed a roast I don't
know if you have this clip handy but I
actually walked up to him up as he's
walking into his camera I can't paint I
had my iPad and I showed him the footage
he just kept saying the same thing I'm
not authorized to speak to the press I'm
not authorized speak to the press I said
Nick you already are in the press in
every local literally every local TV
station KTVI kcwe
ABC new every TV station in Missouri is
playing you right now what do you have
to say he said I can't talk to the press
he's a new - I think there's I don't
know if they're gonna fire these people
or if they're gonna stand behind them
they have admitted they've said what
they've said so in this case no they're
not they're not acknowledging that
they've that that you got me they have
not acknowledged that in this case yeah
I haven't seen anyone acknowledge that
ever at any point I'm just curious you
know you could because it happened with
with with us that we do this Crowder
confronts segments it's not really going
after
politicians but inaccuracy in the media
or people who threatened you know to
kill me and so then we find them and one
was this writer for the Austin Chronicle
who do described an entire video that
was uploaded but never actually uploaded
the video put the video embedded it in
her article that's because she omitted
certain key details like the fact that
the other subject in the video actually
plotted to slash my tires and I said you
know you write in your article that the
six-foot-three Stephen you know
220-pound steven crowder approaches this
and you make really kind of create this
sort of victim and villain scenario but
why didn't you show the video where she
says she did plot she's like well you
you wanted me to quote you on that I
said no don't don't quote me on that
it's in the video you're describing the
person says it there of course that's me
writing that I want to slash your tires
oh so would you like me to quote you on
that Stephen no I don't put anything
just don't don't ya cog the video it is
amazing the kind of I one time I don't
have you ever had this because people
often talk about well this is misleading
and it's unethical for James O'Keefe
right I I think it was Daily Beast I
can't remember who so Daily Beast don't
sue me if I'm just it was some site like
that they were doing some article and
they asked me about something I said
well is this this off the record they
said yeah it's off the record
the article chosen well that's good now
I understand how that works so just lie
about it I have a whole wall in my
office I'm not in my headquarters right
now I'm on the road I have a wall and
it's called wall of shame we have gotten
journalists to print 300 retractions
over the year
my greatest achievement my crowning
achievement his life is when I get a
mainstream journalist to print a
retraction I mean I've got I've got
Washington Post guy one time to print a
retraction about saying that I excluded
something from a video what they're
saying now is that I quote make people
say things I love the pretzel wrangling
of the journalists here with the spin he
makes people say things do newspaper
reporters make you say something or do
you just say it it's just it's just I
mean they know we're living in a very
tribal world where no one's ever gonna
admit fault but that's the beauty of
covert recordings and then they say it's
another go let me just address this for
a minute because yeah I think our world
is changing and I think people need to
know why this is the future these these
surreptitious recordings
we never bug a room were always next to
the first we have no duty to keep
confidential what people tell us no more
than when someone when you right now
what someone says when someone tells you
something you write it down you share it
with the world
right but recordings do it more justice
recordings captured accurately and this
is the necessary thing this is the
future what we're doing and it's and
it's a brave new world with the media it
doubles down they have no shame and the
only way we you know local media is the
way we break through yeah that's a good
point I always wanted that one you know
you're watching the films or you know
you have the April O'Neil's of the
world's going on all right can I get a
quote in the running at 10:00 on a
notepad I'm going you couldn't possibly
ever you couldn't have written all that
down
there's no way vivo doesn't have a
recorder you know back then it would
have had a whole cassette nowadays you
have an iPhone of course it's going to
be more accurate and you also have proof
for somebody else but as we talked about
the left likes to live in the dark what
do you think's gonna happen with this
debate well we have to get going here
and your I appreciate you stopping at
apparently what is the the the patriotic
equivalent of the Bates Motel
but Internet's giving us a little bit of
problems here what do you see happening
with a debate at the desk here i'ma you
can put it on your wall here steven
crowder quote that's great she's sitting
right over there yeah so I will say that
the debate tonight is tonight in
Missouri we've gotten a reaction from
Steve president Steve we've got um we've
got a whole bunch of more videos from
other Senate races coming out in the
coming days ahead okay and stay tuned
it's gonna be a fun two weeks all right
so that's project Veritas calm and of
course people can usually find this on
YouTube and James O'Keefe three eyes do
not enter in the number-three as I just
specified earlier unless you want to
never eat eggs again James thank you for
being here sir we appreciate it
don't be a victim and miss out on lotto
with Crowder's Halloween spooktacular
you of em take over October 25th costume
contest details to follow overflow room
at Pierrepoint Commons lounge kind of
sad when you think about that bunny ran
away our next guest is one of the stars
of the latest film the Gosnell movie of
course we attend a colognian flim on the
program you can follow him at the real
Dean Cain not the at real Dean Cain but
I just say that somebody else you know
what else
also he's also somebody who I often
people often confuse me they say hey are
you like are you a young Dean Cain I say
no i'm steven crowder they go oh I
thought so we often get that in common
how are you mr. Cain I'm doing well I
understand that they give me that time
they're like are you an old steven
crowder I'm like no and bye no bye old
steven crowder they mean current Steven
card I'm getting grey here at thirty-one
and you don't have one are you just
fermenting it or it's just all night go
oh it's uh I have like a little bit here
little little piece here one or two and
then when I grow up my period gets gray
oh look Sajak's gray in there okay well
ten years older are you are you always
tasty are you always tan yeah yeah
because other than Malibu California and
it's gorgeous all the time yeah I don't
have a tan apparently I have a sickly
green color right no but skin cancer
notwithstanding I mean is it like a
racial thing as that you know with your
your ethnically ambiguous sort of
heritage or using that anymore golden
skin cancer notwithstanding no I think I
kind of a green tint to me but it's
always sunny here it's always beautiful
so you're always outside doing things so
I have a bit of a tan and if I don't
have that it's just it's not a good look
really I think it's always an end look
it's not the ethnic makeup the Japanese
in me doesn't does it you know we are
it's certainly the Irish and the English
don't do it okay before we get two guys
down before we get to the Tom Arnold
dust-up have you ever played that up
lexingto the Japanese heritage be honest
for a role have you ever like gone in
F&E maybe tried to dress a little more
stereotypical or like bout a little bit
or spend some more time in the Sun have
you ever used it to your dad let's be
honest no never I don't I played well I
played Latino yeah said it's Italian
I played things like that but I've never
played Asian ever Murray's ever ever
ever ever and you know if I was try to
get into Harvard which why would I do
that
it would be a detriment so no I have not
used the Asian card I haven't played my
Asian car but I promise you I'm more
than one 124 yes exactly I was going
which by the way Asian your land bridge
Native American so you are more native
than a little both warmth Oh probably 20
times as much to be honest
which would make you one you know 400th
or something probably more that you
probably surprised you probably be
surprised you not process alcohol well
with your Asian heritage i I don't know
I don't remember the last time I drank
it was probably last night I just don't
remember I don't from Indians good one
from how to I don't know no the 23andme
I talked about this with with one of my
doctors my my psychiatrist because you
know people don't look he's crazy we did
genetic testing and they've been using
this for quite a while and I'm what they
call a super metabolizer so in other
words it's very difficult for me to get
drunk or when they put me under for
surgery both times I said count
backwards from 10 and I counted
backwards from 10 twice so they had to
up up to the maximum gas dose and they
seemed surprised and they looked into my
genetic and I go okay well this actually
makes sense there's this kind of you
know whatever it is Jen I don't I don't
there's like a there's a whole thing
about it but the point is I sat down
with a doctor but I didn't use it to
necessarily prove that I was one
thousandth 24th
Native American have you seen act other
actors do that though the Elizabeth
Warren to try and get a leg up with
roles no I noticed that at least yeah I
haven't been
involved in that in the casting process
or seeing that possibly it's done Steven
Seagal he's he's gone from being Italian
to I spent all my all of my years with
the blacks in Detroit - then he's
Italian - then Native American come on
dad that's interesting but he you know
he started with the Italian I think he
was in pretty good shape with the
Italian yeah that was Russian
so I don't know have you seen his
Russian dancing you seen anyone this
great like they're doing the other he
it's like a child who doesn't know the
lyrics to a song when I was in French
Canada I remember these kids used to
like simple simple planet mm and they
would try and sing you know the ax
murder - trailer park girls go round the
outside member that quarter black Garret
yeah yeah you know he's like and they
say in English your freshly going to
trap pop go go Rodney offside Ronnie
offside right so that's what it and
Stephen Segal dancing they're doing this
hole and he literally goes like this and
he's doing it it's just a flip all right
before we get to Gosnell obviously
important movie let's show the clip that
we do have of you had a dust-up with
none other than Tom Arnold what exactly
happened was it did I get this crook he
accused you of being a racist or
something yeah excuse me on Twitter of
being racist and anti LGBT and then said
I was complicit because I spoke at the
Values Voter Summit about the film
Gosnell yeah so he said that you know
because you were there you are guilty by
association and these are the people you
run around with and you're a racist and
your anti all be LGBT well it just turns
out that I was going to do politicking
with Larry King at the same day he was
there right and I saw him on the screen
and I thought is he here that's
interesting
I'm gonna ask him except no Tom for a
long time now we're not great friends
but I've been you know hi how are you
whatever it is friend lady so he came
out and he said hey Dean can't good to
see you give me like a little half hug
and things and I was just like wow I was
there to talk about the thumb goes now
but I thought he didn't see just called
me a racist like five days ago yeah but
he's not saying a word about it and so
then he gets ready to leave I go Tom
yeah you called me a racist yeah what is
that about and then he came over and
then somebody filled it and put it out
there but you know then he was once I
it's the thing that happens with the
Twitter warriors right I'm gonna call
you all these awful things with no
corroboration nothing behind it right
throw out these these these ridiculous
allegations and then there's no
consequence right well I was there face
to face and I said you calling me a
racist and I'm not okay with that or
anti-lgbt right I'm not staying with and
people could go watch the whole clip he
didn't see he just seemed to say what
what where did I say that where did I
say that where did I say that and then
he obviously said it what happened but I
didn't sleep happened after that well he
wanted to he wanted me to show him the
tweet which I didn't have readily
available on my phone maybe he didn't
remember putting it out there yeah I
don't know maybe he was in Canada where
they have legalized marijuana right now
basically I wasn't talking about you I
won't talk about you it was very very am
not apologetic but certainly wasn't
wasn't the guy that he was the next few
days on Twitter where he's like Dean
Cain's actually I mean he saw your guns
and was like I didn't say they don't
look you're talking about on Twitter
call them that to their face is done
what would you have done if he said yeah
I I did that yeah I did that Dean gain
your own G's then I probably would have
come at him with a little stronger
language that maybe maybe got in his
face a little I certainly wouldn't have
fought him unless he won't you strike me
first
yeah I would have to defend myself yeah
vigorously what if he just started
dancing like this for sure because
that's a timid a seizure yeah great
crazy no he's Superman every time that's
it's the it's the Kryptonite for Dean
Cain and real life is just in sin it's
the insanity plea it is bizarre we just
talked with with James O'Keefe about
this Tom Arnold knows that he tweeted
that too and then he continued you know
he just lied but that's just a lie so
did you find that kind of caught you
off-guard because you didn't know how to
react like you don't expect a grown-ass
man to just completely lie to save face
you know this no because he's
and a coward will do anything to get out
of a tough situation so no I didn't I
didn't expect that he would say you are
damn racist and bla bla bla
because if he'd done that then he was
least secure in his convictions but I'm
farther I'm the farthest thing from a
racist or a white supremacist or anti
LGBT I mean it's ridiculous
so I mean it's just completely
ridiculous he knew it he wasn't gonna
win that argument he wasn't gonna
convince me I was a racist or anti LGBT
or anything like that or white
supremacists
you know Japanese dude named Tanaka just
looking gonna happen yeah what you
should just slap down your 23andme and
said all right Tom your move and then
say I think you're the white
supremacists oh my face just a racist
I'm not sure what that's about
and then he also said the film Gosnell
was some putrid pile of you know
whatever we thought this was like four
days before it was released right a date
for a it was like four days for this
release and I know he didn't see one of
the screenings so how did he know that
was a terrible movie
yeah that's interesting to me because
why would he why would he say that
you know it seems to me that the you
know you have a lot of conservatives who
said it's who've rightfully said it's
one of the socially most important films
in years and one thing I think about
Gosnell you know a lot of people think
that you find common ground in the
center
I actually don't I think sometimes you
find common ground with people by by
looking at the most radical among us for
example people who consider themselves
Pro pro-life or a pro-abortion still
look at Gosnell and go alright we can
agree on that we're not agreeing in the
middle we're agreeing on the crazy
so most people that I've seen on the
Left have said yeah Gosnell is a monster
but some people how was the reaction
been overall overall it's been extremely
positive I keep hearing people talk
about how they saw the film and its
family members and friends of families
and people that I know and trust and
they say they saw the film in a decently
crowded theater and it was dead silent
through the through the credits and then
it's sparked conversation and this thing
that people are talking about days and
days afterward and it sticks with them
and they're having the conversations
because it's the kind of film that you
makes you think twice I'm a pro-choice
guy up until viability of the fetus not
for my own life I'm completely pro-life
in my own life I just wouldn't if I were
a legislator if I were a lawmaker
racist disagree on that we can have a
conversation and that's great yeah and
you know inviability of 20 weeks at five
months is over fifty percent and at 25
or 26 weeks it's at ninety percent I
mean so and most most states have that
as their law is 20 and 24 weeks in there
and then unless there's you know
extenuating circumstances it's illegal
which is by the way considered really
radically if you look at the more
liberal countries in Europe we allow it
to go very very late and the fight
here's one thing I will say with that
you mentioned viability obviously I'm
pro-life and I wanna get into a whole
debate about it but that argument the
more science comes in the ironically the
less viable that argument is because
today for example say you have a baby
that's born in New York City it's viable
because it's you know in Lenox Hill
Hospital versus the hills of West
Virginia
Wells is one of life and one isn't and
so it's it's not really it's not
something that can be applied
consistently I agree with my issue with
it but with with Gosnell I that's not
even question three with you yeah
wholeheartedly I agree with you and and
governmental change is incremental and
it should be incremental yeah and I
agree with that a hundred percent I just
don't want to legislate giving
government more power in that sense over
what women can do with their body to a
certain degree
once it's somebody that's buy it once
it's a viable child then I think you
have to put the foot down I don't want
it in my own life I'm 100 percent
pro-choice in my life my life in my
choice now monoblock see the fraud yeah
me i a girl that I was dating that
boarded a child and that was one of the
most devastating things in my life yeah
so I lived through it and I wasn't
informed of the choice I could imagine
you that's something that's often we're
stripped of that office I said well no
penis no opinion signaling and it took
two people to make that baby and just
because physically you are not basically
the vessel for the baby at that point
and I get it that's a wonderful miracle
of life it doesn't mean that you don't
have a say and I've known several people
where this has happened what your story
is not not all too dissimilar from many
people listening and that turns a lot of
guys very pro-life but this is kind of a
good example right we don't agree on
everything when it comes to abortion but
we both agree on Gosnell and do you
think that's why the film has been so
it's been more widely well received and
I
anticipated do you think that's a
portion as to why it could be I mean I
think people honest to goodness really
had no idea what this guy was doing they
didn't understand that he was inducing
live birth to viable children then
they're out and they're viable here's a
live child and then snipping their
spinal cords to ensure fetal device they
didn't realize that's what he was doing
and there's examples you know we're the
film isn't graphic the film doesn't show
horrible things but you see the
emotional toll it takes on the mothers
the women who had had abortions women
women who changed their mind there's one
of a woman who changes her mind in
between them they couldn't that he
couldn't change her mind you know she
said he said no you can't you can't
change your mind party started
she's like no and she bolted out of
there had her child you know and she
gives an incredibly powerful testimony
it's so the film isn't it isn't gory but
it really it'll make you think that
it'll make you talk about it and the way
that we should be talking about it and
the truth is there's probably clinics
like that all over the country right now
that you want to work yeah that they
absolutely do exist all over the country
and one thing again you know take a step
back even further it was go to Planned
Parenthood every go so on that's
sensible well actually Planned
Parenthood they are still taught to
upsell abortion is where they make all
their money we've taught this idea that
I think it's what only 7% of their
profit comes from if 7% of the revenue
comes from abortion for an abortion they
do the math for doctor visit ultrasound
medicine the procedure basically you've
gone in for an abortion but it counts as
one of five services there it is exact
and 60,000 abortions a year that's a big
number right yeah and they are we
actually Abby I forgot Abby Johnson on
the show we ad on the show I believe
actually first before book came out and
she was a former director of Planned
Parenthood and she said we were told to
basically get them in the stirrups and
upsell them on abortion because that's
the only way Planned Parenthood made
money think about it birth control is
effectively free it's a seven dollar
prescription for a lot of the stuff that
they're passing out that is their main
moneymaker so even take Gosnell and
scale it back to that you go home on a
second it's the same kind of business
practices its destructive as a used-car
salesman
what was it like doing this from because
you hear a lot sort of like if Jim
Caviezel needed passion of the christ'
and he got electrocuted
you hear people who get into these roles
that are just kind of deep and sometimes
it takes a little while to pull them out
of
that funk obviously this is dark subject
matter what did it take a bit of a toll
on you was a little bit draining to be a
part of the project and to kind of pull
yourself out of it afterward no not
really
because I've seen some awful things in
my day which is unfortunate you know
going over to Iraq in 2005 and seeing a
lot of guys shot and blown up and things
like that awful spend a lot of time
around veterans and people like that
having become a reserve police officer
myself you see awful things and so you
kind of get used to seeing that I was
playing up the police detective it
doesn't make it okay to see it but you
can compartmentalize to some degree or
the thing is we were shooting the stuff
in the clinic and we're shooting the
clinic stuff and I'm looking at the
stuff there's cats running around and
unsterilized equipment and trash bags
full those quote fetuses and you know
milk cartons in the refrigerator full
fetus isn't babies feet in jars like
having I said the guys they go guys
you know I know we're we're we're doing
this and you set all this stuff and you
put this up aren't we pushing it a
little far I mean are we just taking it
a little far like oh we want to see the
real footage so yeah let me show me the
real stuff that goes sure show me the
real footage exact yeah almost exactly
the same the place was a house of
horrors you know for coming in and
getting checked and things like that and
leaving with venereal diseases right
because he was he wasn't sterilizing
equipment he was making about a million
eight a month
normally I guess a year I'm sorry a year
and he was also dealing drugs and
definitely thinks he did nothing wrong
no he thinks he's helping these young
girls out it was it's just a frightening
thing and I just hope people continue to
go out and see themself and and inflam
are meticulous about that I mean they
they do stage plays that are entirely
based on transcripts in court testimony
so it's not the kind of thing they would
mess around was because their entire
reputation does rest on accuracy
we're so where can people find out where
as to where it's playing near them
Gosnell movie.com Gosnell Gosnell
gos any ll movie.com and it'll show you
I'm gonna go see it today again I can't
very good well don't say well I'm a
Cylon it's the somber film come on leave
the room let me take my son to see it
because I think it's important for him
to see it he's 18 yeah and I think it's
really important for him to see it
because he doesn't really have a thought
process on it now he doesn't happen he's
not thinking about being a dad better
not be
and it doesn't make any sense to him but
he has he doesn't really have any stat
tabula rasa you know a blank slate he's
gonna go in there and be horrified and
I'm glad I want me to be yeah it's kind
of like you know if a kid you catch him
smoking a cigarette and then you make
him smoke the entire pack yeah well not
exactly but you know it was unplanned
French Canada you pretty much start with
a whole pack anyway really quickly I
know you have some other probably I
think you were you said you were filming
like two films last week that you can
kind of tease a little bit for people or
no the biggest thing I want to tease now
is a documentary exact produced again I
did the one about the Armenian Genocide
that's been huge Architects of denial
currently doing one called hate among us
which just deals with the rise of
anti-semitism throughout the world and
and the rise in the number of people who
are denying that the Holocaust took
place so it's kind of a strange world
you know that people no no that didn't
happen oh sure you know like like
comedies yeah who say you know in other
words the Holocaust it didn't happen
that's just you know not the case we're
doing a documentary on that which I'm
really happy to promote and talk about
and okay you know I also did the kitten
ball yesterday for Hallmark so that's
very good everyone thanks for the kick
yeah
hey you want to see what happens with
the little long tails and the power to
Panthers you know I don't like the
hallmark either has you on retainer or
speed dial because but it's they have me
on a speed IR speed dial retainer it's
actually I love Christmas and I love
listen I say yes to a lot of projects
I'll do projects with friends of mine
who are making a little hundred thousand
dollar movie because they need you know
you need people to say yes and why not
why not work on a I'm an actor yeah no I
understand I love watching those could I
have hallmark on a loop sometimes it's a
little much sometimes for my god right
listen to the same one like the last
movie in the next movie let's okay let
me put on a break for a bit let me go
watch Scrooge or something but a very
good one so they are manian genocided it
that I know that documentary is out
there and you don't listen the worst
case scenario you deny the immune
genocide you just get the biggest
biggest most highly supported YouTube
news channel there is and you know you
become the main host of it yeah that's
how that works right all right Dean Cain
at real Dean Cain come on back when you
have that dad come on back for any
reason we always it's been in spin a
spell since you've been here I do this
town ain't big enough for the two of us
actually the matter of fact
geographically there is fiscal room for
I've had enough of yours bestest elated
smug talk fill your tumbler you son of a
louder with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter and hopper join
the mud club because I've seen a lot of
mugs in my day and this is by far the
best this could function as a weapon
it's got a lot of girth wait that's not
at all what we heard first of its much
it's not the mug Club it's mug club as a
matter of fact saying mug Club instead
of the mug club the fact they'd even
have to specify that means it's really
it is the only one that matters
Ukraine's like that's just Ukraine not
the Ukraine yeah exactly yeah
come on taking them atop mug club has a
girthy weighty claw mug also were
sponsored by Walter by the way great
sponsor Walt I'm gonna take it from here
great sponsor with Walter Motor Club
nine million dollars annually for those
people listen the free content you see
is ironically supported by the premium
content so even if you don't want to
watch the show or the entire CR TV
lineup or get this wonderful exclusive
hand etched hand-painted mug you still
get to support the content of course we
do this show every single day behind the
paywall live people saying where's the
rest of the Love Guru life advice
segments that's if you join Michael 9
amp dollars annually a lot of credit
come flush my club 69 if you're student
veteran active military of course next
week during the live show we will have a
specific promo code during the U of M
spectacular see you then on with the
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's the drowning queen who was trying
to be sexy with the drowning man soon
realize who's gonna die Thank You Dean
Cain and to James O'Keefe Jimbo keeps
the third we really appreciate ya thank
you so much everyone who's been your
great show great few weeks of shows next
week
huge show at U of M and like I said it's
sold out but as at the point place what
is it uh we just listed it it's up on
the website there is a new overflow room
will be doing giveaways costumes one's
gonna be there Eric Nimr and Gerald some
surprise guests and it's a spectacular
costume contest bring your costumes make
it a lot of fun more offense as a
costume the header but you know it has
to be something it's not a security risk
so next week no man on the road there's
going to be another tough love with blue
credit a life advice Eggman so send your
send your is it life advice a lot of
credit outcome I think so send your
emails in yes so what you want us to
help you with that will go up Monday and
then we'll just kind of have some
updates because we will be on the road
going to U of M setting up Thursday so
Tuesday Wednesday will not be normal
shows big show we're looking forward to
it going going back home really this
this show started a lot of little know
this effectively as an AM radio show up
in Ann Arbor Detroit when it started
before that I had just done YouTube
videos short form videos but then it's
heard as a three hour morning show and
then developed into what you see now so
looking forward to getting back there
and of course being protested speeding
which is something I wanted to talk
about I know the last couple of last
couple of episodes it's been practical
advice but has necessarily been
inspiring this is something that
actually when I was up north here taking
a semi long weekend that that hit me um
Halas I can get quarter block say
something what's up man that's terrible
drink some water for people listening if
you're not listening by the way you can
always a download iTunes lot of people
saying well if I'm on the road YouTube
doesn't work downloaded iTunes yeah
catalog yeah that's the one thing that
doesn't go down Muslim yeah yeah there
you go
I was up north with my wife and she has
a friend I'm trying to think of how to
do this without I don't I never want to
reveal personal information that
embarrasses anyone this is a friend of
the family just a tremendous woman whose
husband had passed away in the last I
think a year and a half and she was
talking about how hard it was and when
we asked how she was doing you know it's
one of those things where you often ask
how are you doing in he leaves your
mouth and you realize oh wait this is
who I'm talking you someones whose
husband just died and you feel terrible
but she didn't hold that against us but
sure tell me how how hard it was short
timeout maybe getting a gun because she
lives in a remote area she was talking
about how lonely you know it was how
hard it was just to adapt to being alone
and then she talked about something
specific that stood with me she said
that her furnace went out and should
that's what drove her off the edge she
said it was just what she said it was
just one more thing in the furnace went
out and I saying how am I have to fix
this and she said something that I think
we've all said to ourselves and I've
heard a lot and I read the salon the
emails Lisa me she said I just I don't
think I can handle one more thing I'm at
the point where I just can't handle one
more thing is what she said that's stuck
with me what I'm about to say by the way
do not take it anything less than
completely sympathetic to this woman in
a horrible situation and a lot of people
out there going through similar
situations some people going through
situations that are even worse some that
might not be as bad matter of fact not
to get too much off on the tangent but
that's why we're going to U of M so I
created an overflow party after the the
room got full though the auditorium the
theatre caught completely full and
hosted by Eric Nimr because listen we
know that on campuses especially places
like Ann harbor no one has been other do
one has been marginalized more than
right-leaning more than conservative
students doesn't matter if you're black
you're yellow white male female trans if
you're conservative on campus you've got
some crap to deal with you've been
berated by students or by the current
mobs the n-word we're not supposed to
say you've been failed by professors
you're afraid to speak out and every now
and then you probably has come to that
point where you say I just I don't think
I got you get an F on a paper I just
don't think I can handle one more thing
now I'm not saying that to compare it to
someone whose husband died the point is
everyone has a different burden to bear
and it got a kid a little kid loses his
toy it doesn't like a big deal to us in
his scope of reality that's the worst
thing that's ever happened to him he's
everything to compare it to so I
understand that for a lot of people this
seems as big of a deal we've often
thrown our hands up sigh I just don't
think I can handle one more thing you're
at that point you're at the edge and
that's what this lady said those words I
just don't think I can handle one more
thing here's the good news for you you
can
you can handle one more thing often I
see people and I get these emails I'm at
the end of my rope I don't know that I
can handle one more thing the good news
is you usually almost always can now
don't misconstrue what I'm saying here
and what I'm about to say I'm not saying
that you should be living your life in a
constant state of crisis where you
always feel like you're at the end of
you're up
you're always redlining the engine
because that that's a bad thing
okay I've talked about that you don't
want to be that and that's why it's so
important to push yourself in a
controlled environment to learn your
limits so that you aren't constantly
pushing them so I'm not saying you can
always take one more thing yeah yeah
take everything like no no your life
should not be that way constantly what I
am talking about here is when life has
put you in a situation where you feel
overwhelmed I know a lot of you do I
felt that very recently actually where
you feel like I just can't handle one
more thing I know a lot of you out there
feel that way and so I want to offer you
encouragement but you know what I know
that encouragement is not just done
through feelings so let's do something
pragmatic let's do a thought exercise
here I want you to do me a favor okay
actually whatever you're doing take a
second take a deep breath I want you to
think back to the hardest point that you
can remember in your life okay it's not
pleasant I know I want you to think back
to the last time you said to yourself I
mean I just don't I just don't think I
can handle one more thing how long ago
was that
where were you when that happened it how
did you feel what led to that I want you
to actually put yourself back in that
moment in time okay are you there now
how are you here today here now is this
is your current situation the way you're
feeling now is it worse than that one
because you made it through that when at
that point you didn't think you could
handle one more thing and whether that
was five years ago that was two months
ago guess what you're here
you not only handled one more thing you
probably had to handle five ten twenty
hundred more things and you're still
here and for the most part if you put
that moment of your life you're probably
better off no no again if you're being
you removed from that chapter having
handled that or multiple more issues
that arose you're probably a better
place now than you were then let me also
let me ask you a Kevin maybe that's not
the case there's some people out there
maybe the problem you're facing right
now is actually legitimately worse than
this situation that you thought of in
your head well the situation that was
previous
the hardest time in your life and you're
answering this question gonna actually I
think right now it says this is worse
here's the good news
I know this isn't going to sound like
good news you'll probably have a harder
situation down the line than this one
which means it down the line you'll be
looking back at this situation even
though it's harder than the one you just
pictured five or ten years ago but five
or ten years from now you'll look back
on this as a time where you said I can't
handle one more thing and you did it
anyway
you handled one more thing I'm not
saying that what you're going through
isn't hard I'm not saying that it
doesn't suck I'm not even saying that
this isn't the kind of situation that
has brought people to their knees before
I'm not saying that someone's husband
dying is an absolutely horrifying thing
it doesn't matter what it is it could be
cancer it could be toxic relate you
could have lost a relationship my point
is just as surely as there have been
people who've been conquered by this
before there have been people who've
beaten it there have been people who've
come before you whatever it is that you
are dealing with right now whatever it
is people have come before you and
thought man I just I just I can't handle
one more thing and they could they did
and they're better for it and these
people are often successes and you don't
even know it a lot of the people who we
see we go man I wish it could be them
they're so successful there's some
stairs some pain in those people that
you probably will never even know and a
big difference is when it came to that
time man I just don't think I can do one
more thing they did the point is this
almost invariably when you say I just
can't handle one more thing good news
you're wrong you almost always let me
rephrase that don't even think of it as
saying anything to yourself - I can
handle look at that voice that voice
saying you came that's not you so right
now make that decision that the voice
you hear saying I'm at the end of my
rope I don't think I can handle one more
thing it's not you it's a voice saying
you're at the end of your rope it's a
voice saying you can't handle one more
thing now even know who that voice is
maybe maybe you're a paranoid
schizophrenic maybe you did bath salts
maybe did too much dad before his
dribble cortex was fully developed I
don't know that guy that voice that's
another guy you're the guy or girl who
can always take one more thing decide
that you're the guy or girl when that
voice says I only can handle one more
thing responses pipe down
they're like Phil Hartman and turbo man
another reference that takes action now
get if you find yourself living on this
edge all the time this is important you
have a problem there are things you're
can you can control I've talked about
and there are things that you can't you
can control having a through-line of
balance in your life you can control
rest and recovery with hard work and not
redlining that engine all the time do
not misunderstand this but the fact is
there's a lot more out there that you
can't control cancer a death in the
family like we said bad relationships
the factor where you work shut down I
don't know what it is you got an F on
your paper because Charles Hermes is
your professor and he didn't like that
you said something about socialism
sometimes you get some tough French okay
that's out of your control and sometimes
you get a string of them but you do not
have to let them beat you and when you
hear that voice and it's not your voice
saying I just don't think I can handle
one more thing if you give into it you
allow those traumas to define you and it
will bother you for the rest of your
life I've asked this question a lot it's
a question I often ask of people who are
the best in any situation where there
was a Brendan Schaub George st. Pierre
you know what's harder to accept the
mistakes that you could have avoided
where you go back no oh I should have
done this or when you've done everything
right when you've done everything
correctly and you've come up short
anyway almost invariably
the people who are successful the people
who are the best in their given field
say I think it's when I made a mistake
myself because they can sleep they can
put their head in the pillow saying I
know I know I did my best
there was nothing else in my control
that I could have improved upon if you
don't if you don't these these issues
will bother you for the rest of your
life so for those of you out there feel
like you can't handle one more thing let
me read the good news as you can and I'm
not just saying hang on like a poster of
a cat on a fireman's pole I'm not just
saying hey hang in there buddy I'm
saying fight back it doesn't matter that
you're at the end of your rope it
doesn't matter that right now you feel
like you can't handle one more thing you
can and whatever that thing may be give
it hell choose right now that voice is
not yours you will not allow it to
define you and the good news is even
though it's gonna suck it might be
painful you can handle one more thing
into those feeling like this at the
University of Michigan reinforcements
are on the way
October 25th we're gonna see you there
power center get ready see you next week
[Music]
you